baubeginn der mondstation die nasa hat
jetzt einen milliarden auftrag für die
administration vergeben somit ist
entschieden welches unternehmen das
wohnmodell halo für den mond außenposten
bauen wird es wird ein
rüstungsunternehmen sein mit einem
seltsamen motto auch die europäische
weltraumagentur esa ist mit einem start
klicks auf youtube dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen arbeiten und wohnen
im mond orbit realisiert werden soll das
mit hilfe des wohnmobils halo die
abkürzung steht für habilitation in
logistics outpost halo und stellt eine
zentrale komponente des luna gateway dar
das den mond als dreh und angelpunkt für
boden mission umrunden soll hier sollen
die astronauten astronauten also
möglicherweise schon in wenigen jahren
leben und arbeiten eine art home office
im mund orbit also die nasa hat nun den
milliarden auftrag vergeben und somit
entschieden welches unternehmen halo
bauen wird die mondmissionen artemis
wird somit immer konkreter wer genau
wird das wohnmodell realisieren und wie
wird es aussehen und wie wird das leben
und arbeiten der astronautin astronauten
im mond orbit vonstatten gehen die
spannenden antworten auf all diese
fragen geht es hierbei klicks zum
science in future in wenigen jahren
könnten wie der menschen auf dem mond
landen und das ist der große coup der
nasa mehr als 50 jahre nach der letzten
mondlandung soll dann also auch eine
frau teil der besatzung seien eine echte
premiere auch eine person auf color soll
dabei sein und mit auf dem mond landen
dazu der nasa wissenschaftler james
green geplant ist dass 2024 eine
bemannte landung auf dem mond
stattfinden soll diesmal soll aber kein
mann sondern eine astronautin zuerst
aussteigen insgesamt für das team aus
vier oder fünf astronauten bestehen zwei
oder drei auf dem mond einer oder zwei
in der umlaufbahn gut
2024 ist nicht mehr zu halten aber so
wie es jetzt aussieht wird es nicht viel
später inhaltlich möchte sich die nasa
am südpol des mondes vor allem mit dem
wasser als beschäftigen dass dort in der
vergangenheit aufgespürt worden ist den
besten fall könnte es in sauerstoff und
wasserstoff aufgespalten werden die
chancen stehen gut dass der erste teil
der mission artemis noch in die diesem
spätherbst statt findet hierbei wird ein
unbemanntes orion raumschiff in die
umlaufbahn des erdtrabanten geschickt
übrigens angetrieben mit deutscher
technologie denn die sogenannten
european service moduls ism wurden
hauptverantwortlich in bremen gebaut von
forschenden des deutschen zentrums für
luft und raumfahrt bei dem es zwei geht
es zunächst um die umrundung des mondes
mit einer besatzung und mit artemis 3
ist dann tatsächlich die mondlandung
gemeint noch in diesem jahrzehnt sollen
also wieder menschen zum mond fliegen
und dann auch für längere zeit dort
bleiben doch die anforderungen an eine
zukünftige mondstation sind erheblich
die umgebung auf dem erdtrabanten ist
extrem und lebensgefährlich und dafür
muss die basis ihre bewohnerinnen und
bewohner natürlich schützen wer sich
hier aufhält muss nicht nur mit dem
sonnenwind und der kosmischen strahlung
klarkommen auf dem mond ist man auf dem
bombardement durch meteoriten mehr oder
weniger schutzlos ausgeliefert hinzu
kommt es gibt kein magnetfeld keine
schützende atmosphäre und kann
sauerstoff die temperaturen schwanken
extrem bis zu 120 grad kann sich die
mondoberfläche durch die sonnenstrahlung
aufheizen in der mond nacht und im
schatten dagegen herrschen temperaturen
von minus 223 grad celsius doch nicht
nur auf dem mond selbst sollen in den
kommenden jahren menschen landen und ihn
vor ort erforschen auch ein luna gateway
ist geplant also eine raumstation die im
mund orbit kreist ein außenposten der
menschheit im all vergleichbar mit der
iss der internationalen raumstation
diese station soll den mond umkreisen
und robotern und astronautinnen
astronauten als basis zur erforschung
der mondoberfläche dienen doch das
gateway könnte auch als zwischenstopp
dienen wenn astronauten und astronauten
in der mondumlaufbahn pausieren wollen
von mir aus könnte sie als plattform und
ausgangspunkt aller flüge zur
mondoberfläche dienen der ehemalige esa
chef jan wörner hatte sie mal bezeichnet
als eine zitat bushaltestelle um auf die
oberfläche zu kommen das luna gateway
wird den nasa plänen zufolge etwa ein
sechstel so groß werden wie die
internationale raumstation iss sie wird
den mond in einer umlaufbahn umkreisen
die 3000 bis 70.000 kilometer vom
erdtrabanten entfernt ist zum vergleich
die iss befindet sich in einer bahn höhe
über der erde von gerade mal 400 km esa
und nasa hatten lange überlegt welche
umlaufbahn sich am besten für eine
solche lunare raumstation eigene einige
voraussetzungen gibt es zu erfüllen zum
einen muss sie möglichst energiesparend
von der erde aus erreichbar sein und zum
anderen aber auch weiter flüge zum mars
und zu anderen weiteren zielen
ermöglicht natürlich sollten auch
menschen und material möglichst ohne
großen aufwand zur mondoberfläche und
zurückgebracht werden können zu dem
natürlich auch ohne zu großen treibstoff
verbraucht seit zwei jahren also seit
2009 10 steht fest dass der lunare geht
wenn nicht im niedrigen motorboot
kreisen soll wie einst das kommando
module der apollo-mission eine stark
exzentrische umlaufbahn wurde
letztendlich ausgewählt die mond
raumstation wird also einem orbit folgen
der sie alle sieben tage bis auf 3000
kilometer an die mondoberfläche
heranbringt am anderen extrem ihrer bahn
ist sie 70.000 kilometer vom
erdtrabanten entfernt konkret besteht
das fundament des gateways aus einer
antriebseinheit pp und dem halo blog die
die basis bilden das antriebsmodul power
and passion element hat eine leistung
von 60 kilowatt und soll die station mit
solarenergie versorgen auch die
manövrierfähigkeit in der umlaufbahn und
eine hochgeschwindigkeits kommunikation
sollen damit sichergestellt werden
weitere module sollen dann andocken
können auch raumfahrzeuge wie das orion
raumschiff der nasa am mond lande geräte
und logistische versorgungsfahrzeuge
können hier als besucher anlegt dass
halo wird quasi so etwas wie das home
office für die geplanten mond mission
sein die astronauten den astronauten
werden ihnen nicht nur leben sondern
auch arbeiten und forschen weitere
wohneinheiten könnten an halo angedockt
werden und so weiterer wohnraum für
astronauten den astronauten geschaffen
werden das design von halo wird wohl an
dass der zyklus raumschiffe angelehnt
sein dass bislang 15 versorgungsmission
zur internationalen raumstation iss
absolviert hat jetzt hat die nasa auch
endgültig entschieden wer das home
office im mund orbit bauen soll denn der
offizielle auftrag ist jetzt raus und
zwar geht der halo auftrag an den us
kampfjet hersteller northrop grumman die
nasa zahlt dem unternehmen das sich
hauptsächlich in der rüstungsindustrie
einen namen gemacht hat insgesamt 935
millionen dollar dafür das unternehmen
hatte bereits vor einiger zeit ein für
halo eingereicht northrop blumen
produziert aber nicht nur kampfflugzeuge
sondern betreibt auch weltraumforschung
und verteidigung auf seiner website
schreibt das unternehmen dass man wisse
was wichtig sein zitat umzugsteilnehmer
zu schützen und die freiheit zu bewahren
sowohl im weltraum als auch vom weltraum
aus das unternehmen hat von der nasa
aber nicht nur den auftrag bekommen halo
zu entwerfen und zu bauen auch für den
transport und die startvorbereitungen
soll northrop blumen verantwortlich sein
das integrierte raum fahrzeuge sollen
nach plänen der nasa möglicherweise im
november 2024 starten es von drei
monaten im april 2021 war ja die
entscheidung gefallen dass dies mit
hilfe einer falcon heavy stattfinden
soll jedem us-unternehmen spacex soll
auch die mondlandefähre bauen auf basis
des chips mit der die astronautin
astronauten nach 2024 auf dem mond
landen werden dass mondlandefähre modell
heißt human landing system ios und soll
zwei besatzungsmitglieder samt
ausrüstung zur mondoberfläche bringen
ungefähr eine woche sollten sich die
beiden personen dann auf dem mond
aufhalten basics hatte sich damit gegen
die beiden konkurrenten blue origin von
amazon gründer jeff bezos und dynamics
durchgesetzt ja und besseres jeffers
klagt ja gegen die nasa wegen dieser
entscheidung aber ich glaube nicht dass
das so aussichtsreich ist die
entscheidung scheint wirklich gefallen
zu sein auch die europäische
weltraumagentur esa ist wird am start
von ihr soll ein lineares
kommunikationssystem kommen mit dessen
hilfe zwischen dem gateway und der
mondoberfläche kommuniziert werden kann
und das mit einer hohen datenrate zudem
möchte die esa auch ein auftakt modul
beisteuern doch wie realistisch ist eine
zeitnahe landung auf dem mond bereits
anfang des jahres 2021 hatte die nasa
selbst zugestanden dass der mut im jahr
2024 wohl keine menschen sehen wird wir
hatten hier exklusiv darüber berichtet
doch das liegt wohl eher an fehlenden
finanziellen mitteln dazu der nasa
mitarbeiter steve jobs das ziel der
mondlandung 2024 könnte ein
unrealistisches seien angesichts der
budget zuteilung der letzten beiden
jahre die nicht genügend mittel bereit
gestellt haben um 2024 erreichbar zu
machen von diesem hintergrund überprüfen
wir das projekt hinsichtlich des
effizientesten weges viele fachleute
befürchten dass das 2024 erzielt das
damals noch von donald trump
herausgegeben worden war unter joe biden
wieder verschwinden wird doch auf der
anderen seite steht auch fest für die
usa steht viel auf dem spiel und auch
china und russland haben ambitionierte
pläne für eine mondlandung die ganze
welt will zum mond exklusiv mondlandung
für 2024 gestrichen das ist das video in
dem wir exklusiv erstmals über die
entscheidung berichtet haben anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren dann kennt ihr
alle hintergründe zu der spektakulären
entwicklung bis dann da dran